a good friend of mine ivan reitman
yeah died in his sleep last night a
month ago i was sitting at my desk and i
said geez i haven't
spoken with ivan reitman in a really
long time and it feels weird because we
got very close during the making of
private parts
he's always been a mentor to me he's
always been a terrific guy to me he's a
huge fan of the show we used to listen
every day and i remember years and years
ago before we made the film private
parts i was always impressed that ivan
reitman the great film director the guy
who made ghostbusters 300 million dollar
growth but a funny film forget that
the guy who made animal house the guy
who made
um meatballs
dave
uh you name it this guy
who made all these funny films is a fan
of mine
it just tickled me you know because i'm
such an admirer of his movies i picked
up the phone a month ago and i called
ivan
and he was so happy to hear from me
and um he sounded great
when we spoke we had just the best time
talking on the phone it was a big love
fest love you loved this one loved that
one i felt so good about touching base
with ivan because i never want to be out
of touch with the guy because i'll tell
you why
this guy saved my life
i felt such pressure to get that film
private parts done and here was my
pressure
21
different
opportunities were taken to come up with
the script and we couldn't do it i wrote
one of the scripts with another guy one
time it was all based on my father and
our relationship and our blah blah blah
blah blah was a piece of [ __ ] and i
wrote it
yeah
i was racking my brain trying to figure
it out and so many talented people and
the movie studio who was putting up
money for all these drafts
was saying you know they bought the the
book private parts and they wanted the
movie rights and they go listen man come
on already you got to make the movie
it was reicher entertainment they wanted
a hit movie
and they were like pressuring me you
know come on one of these scripts isn't
good enough for you what is with you and
my agent don buckle was like howard's
not happy with the script and my agent
got me script approval thank god because
they would have made any one of these
shitty scripts and then at some point
they were threatening me
we're gonna get jeff goldblum to uh play
you and you won't even be howard stern
and i said you got to be kidding me i
said i'd like to see that movie jeff
goldblum plays howard stern yeah just
don't use the name howard stern my agent
don buckwald was walking around l.a
he was gonna pick up some kind of deli
sandwich i think it was a famous place
in l.a where people go to eat deli
and don walks he sees ivan on the street
and don being the kind of guy he is this
is why he's a super agent
let me go over and talk to this ivan
reitman say hello
the next thing i knew ivan was on the
phone with me and he said listen i read
your book i got the whole movie he goes
this is the this is what should happen
he started explaining to me on the phone
the movie
the way he kind of saw a big picture of
it
i said jesus christ
you're right
it's simple that's it
i go ivan oh god i wish you were
involved
all right they got on the phone with
reisher blah blah blah they made ivan
the executive producer he got a
you know they wet his beak you
understand robin
yes i do
yeah listen i have a name working for
free just to get him to be interested
was a miracle i was like how could i
miss now with this movie i got the
greatest filmmaker ivan reitman involved
i'm gonna be the [ __ ] man here
well ivan said you prepared to work i go
yeah what are we doing he says i know a
guy i think would be great to write this
thing his name's lenny bloom out of
canada
i said oh okay he says he's gonna write
it and here's how we're gonna do it
you guys get together i want you to do a
deep dive go through everything
and i would sit there with lenny i tell
them about my best bits what i was
thinking during them blah blah blah blah
we met for i don't know a couple of
months or maybe i don't know i don't
even remember lenny was out of my house
we were writing together ivan said
lenny's going to go back and write
and uh he'll he'll send me pages every
couple of days and i'll edit them and
sure enough
ivan went off with lenny
when he sent the pages i talked to lenny
boom
gotta script back that what my agent
called me goes we finally got a script
let's let's uh green light this [ __ ] i
was like oh my god it's such a beautiful
script i couldn't wait to film it ivan
orchestrated that movie and got everyone
on board and he watched every [ __ ]
daily which is the yeah i'm in show
business for you kids out there who
don't know what i'm talking about every
day you shoot and then they send all the
[ __ ] off to ivan so he could see what's
happening
even the first couple of days on this
set
your man here hadn't acted before is
having a couple of rough days i haven't
smacked me around
he literally like kind of [ __ ]
brought me into room goes what the [ __ ]
are you doing
i go i don't know what i'm doing
because you're playing yourself
and you and your ad libby on the set you
got lines and other actors have to know
when to come in i go they do
can't they read my mind
i'm he goes listen go up to your room
and learn your lines and
come down here
can act like a man so uh he he smacked
me around came down i started doing some
acting some damn good acting i got
robbed at the academy
i knew i even liked the finished product
when he said uh damn i should have
directed this movie he was jealous a
little bit
and he said to me i'm putting my name on
this movie ivan was on our show a couple
of times you know had him in always fun
to talk to him about all his movies and
the people
yeah yeah he knew everyone he worked
with everyone and real classy guy
sweetheart of a guy
ivan rest in peace it sucks i'm very sad
to hear that he's gone 75 years old and
i know to some people that sounds old
but for me it sounds way too young
so i'm bummed out
because uh first of all friends are hard
to come by when you're me number two
especially friends who made a great
movie with you
and i'm just sad because the guy had so
much talent